bonjour à tous ce matin les sénateurs
examinent lors d'une nouvelle lecture le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2014 lors de la
première lecture mi novembre le sénat a
rejeté ce texte texte qui a ensuite
revenu à l'assemblée nationale c'était
dans ce début de semaine l'assemblée
nationale qui a donc rétabli le texte
dans une version conforme à la vision du
gouvernement l'assemblée nationale qui a
également entériné un certain nombre de
modifications lors de cette nouvelle
lecture notamment un coup de pouce à
l'aide à la complémentaire santé
l'assemblée nationale a également
entériné le recours aux clauses de
recommandations lors des accords de
branche une mesure qui suscite la grogne
parmi les petites mutuelles elles
semblent nationale a également entériné
le recul du gouvernement sur la taxation
de l'ema de l'epargne seul à l'assurance
vie va être conservé par la taxation à
15 5% c'est donc maintenant au sénat
autour du sénat d'examiner ce texte tout
de suite direction des musiques très
bonne séance nous en arrivons à l'ordre
du jour qui appelle la discussion du
projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale en nouvelle lecture de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 dans la discussion générale la
parole est à madame marisol touraine
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
santé
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les députés les
sénateurs pardon
je vous prie tout d'abord de bien
vouloir excuser l'absence de monsieur
bernard cazeneuve ministre déléguée
chargée au budget qui a été retenu par
d'autres obligations
à la suite de l'échec de la commission
mixte paritaire
l'assemblée nationale a procédé lundi
dernier à la nouvelle lecture du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2014 je ne m'étendrai pas
ce matin devant vous sur les avancées de
ce texte et notamment sa contribution à
la mise en oeuvre de la stratégie
nationale de santé puisque j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de vous les présenter en
première lecture je veux insister plus
précisément sur les évolutions
intervenues depuis lors sur le texte et
sur la manière dont elles renforcent les
orientations qui sont celles retenues
par le gouvernement à l'occasion de
l'approché de la présentation de ce
texte budgétaire
je souhaite en premier lieu revenir sur
la trajectoire de redressement que se
traduit ce projet de loi il s'inscrit
dans un double objectif qui est celui
vous le savez de maintenir un haut
niveau de protection sociale pour nos
concitoyens et de poursuivre le
redressement des comptes sociaux je vous
rappelle que cet objectif nous l'avons
affirmé dès l'été 2012 puis dans le
plfss pour 2013 qui ont permis
d'enclencher le redressement des comptes
sociaux
ses choix exigeants qui ont été
effectués nous permettront de ramener
l'an prochain le déficit du régime
général et du fonds de solidarité
vieillesse en deçà de 13 milliards
d'euros je vous rappelle qu'à l'arrivée
aux responsabilités de ce gouvernement
ce déficit était de 21 milliards d'euros
mais ces choix sont exigeants également
parce qu'ils engagent parce qu'il porte
des réformes de structure parce qu'il
vise à renforcer
l'équité de notre système est parce que
nous refusons que l'adaptation de ce
système de santé se fasse sur le dos à
la charge des assurés sociaux notre pays
traverse aujourd'hui une période
d'incertitude et il est donc
indispensable plus que jamais de
consolider les piliers de notre
protection sociale et de marquer le cap
des choix qui sont les nôtres et c'est
le sens des réformes des transformations
structurelles
engagées par le gouvernement
stratégie nationale de santé politique
familiale à venir et justice de notre
système de retraite le parlement a
souhaité adapter certaines des mesures
proposées et présenté par le
gouvernement c'est ainsi que des
modifications ont été apportées aux
recettes de la sécurité sociale
introduction d'une fiscalité sur les
boissons énergisantes
fiscalité des contrats de complémentaire
santé
affectation d'une part de la casa à des
dépenses dès l'année 2014 en direction
des personnes en perte d'autonomie
notamment
le gouvernement a souhaité poursuivre
dans cette voie la première modification
qui avait été d'ailleurs présenté dès le
premier passage au sénat porte sur la
mesure relative aux calculs des
prélèvements sociaux sur les produits de
placement exonérés d'impôt sur le revenu
est assujetti en sortie cette mesure a
fait l'objet de débats et le
gouvernement vous avez proposé un
amendement permettant de l'aménager par
ailleurs face aux difficultés
spécifiques que rencontrent les artisans
et les commerçants le gouvernement a
proposé un amendement permettant de
lisser les hausses de cotisations
retraite pour les artisans et les
commerçants
cette mesure de lissage ne remet pas en
cause le déplafonnement social partielle
des cotisations retraite qui est une
mesure d'équité légitime mais il s'agit
de l'accompagner à l'aune de ces
évolutions l' équilibre financier global
de ce projet de loi sera préservé ces
aménagements ne dégraderont pas le
déficit de la sécurité sociale
en effet le budget de la sécurité
sociale pour 2014 bénéficiera en retour
ou en compensation de la bonne maîtrise
de la dépense résultant de la politique
mise en oeuvre par le gouvernement et
notamment de la très bonne tenue de
l'ondam en 2013 au-delà même de ce que
je vous avais annoncé puisque nous
constatons que les dépenses seront
inférieurs non pas de 500 mhz et 2 650
millions d'euros par rapport à
l'objectif fixé
au terme de ces diverses modifications
donc le sol de 2014 de la sécurité
sociale restera au niveau fixé par le
projet de loi initial à 12 milliards 800
millions d'euros pour le régime général
et le fonds de solidarité vieillesse en
amélioration donc de 3 milliards 400
millions d'euros par rapport à 2013
ce projet de loi au delà des équilibres
financiers
engagés évidemment des orientations en
matière d'assurance maladie il s'agit en
premier lieu j'ai eu l'occasion de le
présenter longuement de poursuivre le
combat pour l'accès aux soins
l'assurance maladie je veux le redire
fermement ici reste et doit rester le
pilier fondamental de la prise en charge
des dépenses de santé cela impose aussi
une régulation de l'offre des
complémentaires santé si nous ne voulons
pas que le déséquilibre qui a été
observé depuis 2004 en faveur d'une
prise en charge par les complémentaires
santé
le s'accroissent une différenciation
plus forte du taux de tva entre les
contrats dits solidaires et responsables
et les autres le permettra en
particulier la réduction du reste à
charge pour les bénéficiaires de l'aide
à la complémentaire santé doit être une
priorité cela se traduira par diverses
mesures inscrites dans ce projet de loi
mise en place d'appels d'offres pour
mieux identifier les contrats dead à la
complémentaire santé
peser sur les prix de ces contrats et
permettre une meilleure prise en charge
en particulier en matière de frais
d'optique des bénéficiaires de l'aide à
la complémentaire santé
par ailleurs l'assemblée nationale a
souhaité compléter les dispositions
initialement prévue par ce texte en
facilitant le recours à l'aide à la
complémentaire santé en prévoyant le
renouvellement automatique du droit à
l'aide à la complémentaire santé pour
les bénéficiaires de l'allocation de
solidarité pour les personnes âgées
anciennement appelée minimum vieillesse
le gouvernement a également présenté en
nouvelle lecture à l'assemblée nationale
un amendement visant à revaloriser de 50
euros l'aide à la complémentaire santé
pour les bénéficiaires de plus de 60 ans
c'est de cette aide aujourd'hui 2 500
euros par an passera donc à 550 euros
c'est une mesure évidemment
particulièrement importante pour une
population dont les cotisations aux
complémentaires sont élevées puisque
l'on sait que les cotisations augmente
avec l'âge dans la mesure où les frais
engagés pour la santé augmente avec
l'âge c'est une population dont le
recours aux soins est important c'est
une population dont le pouvoir d'achat
est souvent soumis à des difficultés et
dans un contexte contraint nous avons
souhaité adresser un signal de pouvoir
d'achat mais aussi faciliter l'accès aux
soins de cette population dont le revenu
je veux le rappeler est compris entre
770 et
967 euros par mois ces dispositions
contribue donc à renforcer notre soutien
de pouvoir d'achat aux retraités les
plus modestes de même que la mesure que
j'ai annoncé il y à quelques jours de la
double revalorisation de l'aide de la
location pardon de solidarité pour les
personnes âgées double revalorisation
qui interviendra à l'année prochaine le
1er avril d'abord le 1er octobre ensuite
c'est une mesure importante puisque
grâce à elle aucune pension ne sera plus
inférieur à 800 euros dans notre pays
ces dispositions seront complétés par
une action spécifique en faveur des plus
fragiles le gouvernement a ainsi aidé
plus vulnérables ceux qui sont
confrontés à des situations
particulières en particules notamment
les situations de handicap ou de perte
d'autonomie le gouvernement a présenté
il ya quelques mois un plan permettant
de renforcer la prise en charge de
l'autisme et les premières dispositions
pour 2014 seront intégralement couvertes
par ce projet de loi nous mettrons
également en oeuvre les engagements au
titre du plan alzheimer je veux
également rappelé qu'avec michèle
delaunay nous porterons dès l'an
prochain une loi d'orientation et de
programmation pour adapter notre société
au vieillissement de la population
la concertation sera lancée par le
premier ministre demain et la
concertation avec l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés au premier rang desquels
figurent les conseils généraux
s'engagera dès la semaine prochaine
c'est dans ce contexte que le
gouvernement a soutenu le soient
exprimés par les parlementaires de
mettre en oeuvre un soutien aux
personnes âgées dès 2014 100 millions
issus de la casa permettront donc dès
l'année prochaine de renforcer la
politique en faveur et en direction des
personnes âgées
ce montant sera affecté pour 30 millions
d'euros au soutien des services d aide à
domicile et pour le reste permettra de
financer un plan des aides à
l'investissement en faveur des ehpad et
d'appuyer plus fortement la rénovation
des foyers-logements ce plan daide
venant évidemment en complément de celui
qui était d'ores et déjà prévues par la
cns à mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs avec ce plfss nous poursuivons
le redressement de nos comptes et la
transformation de notre modèle social
dans la volonté de garantir la
solidarité ans direction de l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens et de permettre que à
travers les choix que nous portons se
retrouve le chemin du progrès je vous
remets ce
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur yves daudigny rapporteur
général de la commission des affaires
sociales
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
le 14 novembre dernier le sénat a rejeté
la troisième partie du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 puis l'ensemble du texte
pour la deuxième année consécutive
un sénat de gauche
rejettent donc un projet de loi de
financement préparé et présenté par un
gouvernement de gauche
laissant à nos collègues députés le
choix de disposer librement des
amendements votés dans cette enceinte et
de façonner un texte pourtant essentiel
pour l'avenir du pays
il y avait pourtant
dans ce plfss
des mesures susceptibles de répondre aux
attentes la coalition je dirais pour le
moins disparates qui composent
aujourd'hui l'opposition sénatoriale
on pouvait espérer par exemple qu'une
partie de cet hémicycle soutiennent ou
moins salue les résultats obtenus par le
gouvernement en matière de gestion des
comptes sociaux je pense bien entendu
ici aux 2,4 milliards d'euros d'efforts
réalisés en 2013 en matière de dépenses
de santé qui se sont notamment traduit
par le respect de l'ondam pour la
quatrième année consécutive
je pense surtout à la réduction des
déficits
entrant dans le champ du plfss
constatée depuis l'arrivée de la
nouvelle équipe gouvernementale aux
responsabilités en deux ans en deux ans
le déficit des régimes obligatoires a
été réduit de plus de 5 milliards le
déficit du régime général a quant à lui
diminué de près de 4 milliards
alors mes chers collègues ce n'est sans
doute pas assez
mais ce n'est pas rien
pas rien surtout lorsque l'on connaît la
difficulté d'un verset l'évolution
tendancielle des comptes sociaux en
période de crise économique et de
ralentissement prononcé de la
progression de la masse salariale
pouvaient également envisager
qu'une autre partie de cet hémicycle se
satisfassent des mesures de justice et
d'équité
présentée par le gouvernement dans ce
projet de loi de financement alors je
pense ici à la refonte des prélèvements
sociaux applicables aux produits de
placement à l'alignement progressif des
modalités de calcul des cotisations
vieillesse des artisans et des
commerçants sur celle des salariés du
régime général
ou encore aux dispositions garantissant
le financement des petites retraites
agricoles
certains de ces dispositifs
ont d'ailleurs été largement amendé afin
de tenir compte des réactions qu'ils ont
pu susciter et d'assurer sans perdre de
vue leur objectif initial leur
application dans les mois à venir
là encore nous sommes tombés dans une
surenchère difficilement compréhensible
aboutissant à supprimer systématiquement
des dispositions qu'en d'autres temps
certains d'entre vous dans cet hémicycle
appelé de leurs voeux au titre de
l'équité entre nos concitoyens de la
justice entre les catégories de
contribuables ou plus simplement de la
simplification de dispositifs fiscaux
dont la complexité grandissante est
devenu un véritable fera ou consentement
de l'impôt
mes chers collègues
si le sénat se trouve une nouvelle fois
dans l'impasse concernant ce projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
il s'illustre par ailleurs cette année
il restait presque nouveau par ses
contradictions
certains reprochent au gouvernement de
ne pas aller assez loin dans la
réduction des déficits
mais ils soutiennent pourtant l'adoption
d'amendements qui en première lecture
ont dégradé les soldes de la sécurité
sociale
de plus d'un milliard d'euros
les autres dénoncé conteste sans relâche
depuis deux mois une diminution de
l'ondam alors que les dépenses de santé
et des ports d'assurance maladie
augmenteront de plus de 4 milliards
d'euros en 2014 il faudra faire preuve
de beaucoup de pédagogie pour expliquer
cette équation à nos concitoyens
mes chers collègues en d'autres termes
les postures que chacune chacun d'entre
nous se plaît à prendre depuis un
certain temps dans cet hémicycle ont un
coût
elle emporte des conséquences qui nous
appartient de bien mesurer
en rejetant un texte
dont nous n'avons pas pu discuter
l'intégralité des articles nous
condamnons une fois de plus le sénat au
silence et à l'impuissance
en refusant collectivement de peser sur
le texte de l'amender de l'améliorer en
décidant de nous priver de ce qui
constitue habituellement l' expertise du
sénat nous acceptons de laisser
l'assemblée nationale décider librement
du contenu d'un plfss sur lequel aucune
aucun d'entre nous n'aurait pu laisser
la moindre remarque
en reconduisant aujourd'hui nos votes
sur la troisième partie puis sur
l'ensemble du texte
en rendant ce que l'an dernier déjà
j'appelais une copie blanche
nous refusons sciemment
d'alimenter le débat démocratique et
faisons le jeu des extrêmes
en nourrissant la défiance de certains
de nos concitoyens à l'égard d'un
travail parlementaire
considérée comme inutile et superflu
en tant que rapporteur général de la
commission des affaires sociales je suis
certes déçu par la tournure la
discussion sur un projet de loi qui
constitue pourtant le point cardinal de
l'année sociale
je reste persuadé persuadé qu'il était
envisageable de faire autrement et de
nous accorder fois n'est pas coutume sur
la possibilité de débattre d'une
quatrième partie contenant les prémices
de la politique du gouvernement en
matière de politique de santé de
vieillesse ou de famille
en tant qu'élu de la république je suis
surtout meurtri comme bon nombre d'entre
vous j'en suis certain par la vision
d'une institution
rélégué au rang de spectateur du
processus démocratique
incapable de faire passer lorsque c'est
nécessaire
l'intérêt général avant des intérêts
partisans
il y a quasiment un an jour pour jour je
vous faisais part à cette même tribune
de ma confiance dans le débat qui allait
s'ouvrir sur la nouvelle lecture du
plfss
il me semblait encore possible de sauver
in extremis un texte finalement rejetée
un an plus tard
malheureusement je n'ai plus aucune
illusion sur le sort qui sera réservé à
ce plfss
à l'issue de nos discussions
lappartient il appartiendra désormais
chacune chacun de prendre ses
responsabilités
dans l'intérêt du sénat de la protection
sociale et de nos concitoyens comme j'ai
pris je prends les miennes en soutenant
sans réserve l'adoption de ce projet de
loi de financement dans la rédaction
issue des travaux de l'assemblée
nationale je vous laisse
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame chantal jouanno
pour le groupe udi uc
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues il nous est
donc à nouveau permis de nous exprimer
sur ce projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale et naturellement
nous nous essaierons obstinément de
faire passer nos messages
obstinément monsieur le rapporteur est
naturellement vous nous expliquerez que
ce projet parfait et que la faute et
celle de vos prédécesseurs
c'est normal et naturellement nous
serons témoins d'un étranger pathétique
une étrange et pathétique inversion des
discours entre la majorité d'hier et
celle d'aujourd'hui mais nous ne pouvons
pas nous résoudre à cette mascarade et
cette absence de dialogue avec les
différents groupes du sénat et je n'ai
aucune illusion comme vous monsieur
rapporteur sur l'issue des débats de ce
jour alors revenons sur le fond
premièrement ce plfss
nous le rappelons nous le considérons
dangereux par l'exaspération qu'il va
créer ce sont 4 milliards de
prélèvements supplémentaires pour nos
compatriotes et la réduction du déficit
dont vous vous targuez est uniquement
liée à cette augmentation des
prélèvements car les dépenses ne font
que ralentir face aux tendancielle et ne
baissent pas deuxièmement ce ne sont pas
les riches qui payent mais tout le monde
je peux citer l'exemple de la taxation
des produits d'être parle certes vous
avez en partie reculée mais cette taxe
demeure inique envers les petits
épargnants nous proposerons donc sa
suppression est fondamentalement nous
pensons que le défaut d'epargne public
n'a pas à être compensées est prélevée
sur les pagnes privé l'épargné privée
elle doit retourner à l'économie privée
pas à la dépense publique deuxième
exemple la taxation des plus modestes
une nouvelle augmentation des
cotisations des indépendants artisans
commerçants exploitants agricoles
peut-on considérer qu'ils sont riches
vous savez que la moyenne annuelle de
leurs revenus et de 32000 euros
al'inverse nous nous considérons qu'ils
n'ont pas à être traités comme des
salariés parce que leur vie sont
différentes et parce qu'ils sont
l'exemple aussi d'efforts ils sont
l'exemple du travail et la vertu des
petits et des entrepreneurs ne doit pas
payer le prix les errances public
troisième difficulté l'épineuse question
de l'organisation du système social est
encore esquiver ce plfss
comme le précédent augmente les recettes
de transfert et la fiscalisation d'une
partie de la dépense sociale ce n'est
pas fondamentalement anormal
à l'exception du bidouillage de la casa
pour le reste par exemple pour les trois
milliards de recettes de transfert de la
tva cela ne nous choque pas et nous
sommes d'ailleurs plutôt favorable à ce
que la dépense sociale soit prise en
charge par la solidarité nationale c'est
vrai pour la dépense concernant la
famille pour la dea plupart des dépenses
de santé bien évidemment pour la
dépendance mais pour autant il faudrait
aller au bout de cette logique il
faudrait donc aller plus loin qu'une
simple hausse de la tva parce que là on
ne rejoint pas vous nous dites mais
après tout précédent gouvernement a
augmenté la tva certes mais en
compensation d'une baisse des charges
sociales vous oubliez toujours la
deuxième partie de la phrase donc il
faudra aller au bout et recréer une tva
sociale conséquente il faudrait aussi
remettre en question de paritarisme si
vous vouliez aller au bout de cette
logique et très logiquement discuter
dans un seul et même texte du plf et du
plfss
quatrième difficulté il n'y a aucune
réforme de la politique de prévention il
ya d'ailleurs aucune politique de
prévention faut-il rappeler que les
principales dépenses et notamment de
l'assurance maladie et une étude très
intéressante de la cnam qui vient de
sortir à ce sujet sont la santé mentale
le diabète et les maladies
cardiovasculaires des maladies qui
pourraient être amplement réduite par
une véritable politique de prévention
alors vous nous renverrait probablement
à la loi de santé publique
l'arlésienne qui était déjà annoncée
pour janvier de l'année 2013 et
oserais-je malicieusement rappelé que
dans le cadre du plf la prévention est
justement le poste sacrifiés du budget
de la santé mais ces propositions vous
les avez tout hautement ignorez vous
n'avez pas écouté gérard roche quand ils
vous parlez
des parcours de soins vous n'avez pas
écouté mes gars de déni quant à elle
évoqué le problème des emplois à
domicile et je ne reviendrai pas sur cet
épisode méprisable est en réalité très
méprisant du vote bloqué en première
lecture
c'est une caricature et monsieur dowd
unis j'ai bien entendu votre discours
vos problèmes avec votre majorité ne
sont pas les nôtres
vous ne vous n'avez pas à nous faire
porter la responsabilité de vos propres
difficultés politiques par contre le
danger démocratique que constituent ces
procédures ces débats cette caricature
qui amène nos concitoyens à rejeter en
bloc les politiques ça ça nous concerne
alors nous voici donc et vous voici dans
une impasse vous allez une nouvelle fois
piétiné le sénat et le principe même
d'ailleurs du débat parlementaire parce
que la dépense sociale est la première
des dépenses publiques nous avons eu 12
heures 30 pour préparer cette deuxième
lecture vous n'avez rien changé dans une
forme d'obstination hautaine et sourde
donc nous ne changerons rien à nos votes
et nous rejetterons ce texte
merci
la parole est à monsieur dominique
watrin pour le groupe crc
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
présidente de commission mes chers
collègues
présenté en sept minutes la position du
groupe communiste républicain et citoyen
sur ce projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2014 pour être
une véritable gageure si celui ci
n'avait fait déjà l'objet d'une première
lecture
pourtant la tâche n'est pas simple dans
la mesure où en plus de la complexité à
et rentrent à une loi de financement
l'examen en première lecture a été
seulement qu'on puisse dire bousculé par
l'utilisation à l'issue nos débats d'une
seconde délibération couplé au vote
bloqué procédure brutal qui a eu
notamment pour effet de supprimer les
amendements adoptés par la haute
assemblée même les amendements issus de
votre majorité n'ont pas échappé à ce
couperet je pense à ceux du rapporteur
comme à ceux des sénatrices et sénateurs
du groupe écologie les verts qui avait
notamment obtenu l'adoption d'un
amendement dont nous sommes les premiers
rédacteurs sur la taxation des retraites
chapeaux
le signal que vous envoyez à tous les
parlementaires est clair il n'y a qu'une
ligne qu'une voix celles décidées par le
gouvernement vous voulez en réalité
ignorée le sénat pl que deux plutôt que
de tirer les enseignements d'une réalité
politique pourtant clair vous n'avez pas
de majorité au sénat pour imposer une
politique d'austérité et cela devient
d'ailleurs de plus en plus vrai à
l'assemblée nationale aussi c'est bien
de cela dont il s'agit et c'est le grief
principal que nous formulons sur le fond
pour ce plfss pour 2014
l'essentiel de ses recettes nouvelles
sont issus de mesures de mesures que
nous estimons injuste et que nous
contestons comme la case attaques sont
les retraités imposé l'année dernière et
une nouvelle fois détournée de son objet
ou encore la taxe sur les contrats
d'assurance vie vous n'avez pas hésité
non plus à augmenter les cotisations
sociales des salariés
tandis que la hausse de la part
patronale sera elle immédiatement
compensé par une baisse équivalente de
cotisation employeur à la branche
famille il est donc faux d'affirmer que
les employeurs sont également mis à
contribution pour le financement de la
réforme des retraites et les besoins de
la sécurité sociale
quant aux mesures d'économie elles sont
là encore des plus injustes le gel des
pensions les bras 800 millions d'euros
aux retraités les établissements publics
de santé dont certains connaissent des
difficultés financières importantes se
voit encore imposé des mesures
d'économies au point que ce plfss
s'apparente à une véritable diète
comment feront ils face à l'augmentation
de dépenses contraintes ce alors même
que la campagne tarifaire de 2013 les a
déjà placé dans une situation économique
des plus complexes j'attire d'ailleurs
votre attention madame la ministre la
demande apparemment légitime de la
fédération hospitalière de france de
pouvoir accéder aux fonds de solidarité
mis en oeuvre pour faire face aux
emprunts toxiques
quant aux établissements médico sociaux
ils sont sans doute mieux traités que
les acteurs du système sanitaire mais
ils devront également faire face à des
mesures d'austérité avec un ondam en
baisse d'un pour cent par rapport à
celui fixé dans le plfss pour 2013 et
cela sans parler des 600 millions
d'euros de la casa qui manqueront cette
année encore aux actions médico social
alors pourtant qu'il y à des urgences
criante ce plfss pour 2014 et donc mars
marquées du sceau de la continuité quand
il faudrait au contraire rompre avec des
mesures qui ont démontré leur
inefficacité et même leur pouvoir de
nuisance disant cela je pense aux
exonérations de cotisations sur les bas
salaires dits exonérations fillon que
vous maintenez ces dernières
contrairement à ce que la droite prétend
est ce que vous semblez croire ne
réduisent pas le coût du travail mais
augmentent massivement les dividendes
que s'octroient les actionnaires les
exonérations de cotisations sociales
celle ci en tout cas jce comme des
trappes à bas salaires qui au final font
rentrer moins d'argent dans les caisses
de la sécurité sociale
pire vous créer de nouvelles et 9,0
exonérations ainsi vous accorder
plusieurs milliards de cotisations
d'exonérations de cotisations sociales
aux employeurs qui mettrait en oeuvre
les clauses de recommandation al'inverse
de l'esprit du conseil national de la
résistance vous fait le choix de
privilégier les organismes
complémentaires au détriment de la
sécurité sociale vous participez ainsi
comme la droite hier inverser les
fondements de notre pacte social en
faisant primer le complémentaire sur
l'essentiel ce que nous ne pouvons
accepter pour toutes ces raisons le
groupe crc ne peut voter en faveur des
recettes prévues dans ce préfet cesse
2014 ce vote nous est d'autant plus
impossible que nous avons formulé des
propositions concrètes et solidaire de
financement que vous n'avez eu de cesse
d'écarter en première lecture comme
d'ailleurs l'année passée c'est le cas
de la modulation des cotisations
sociales en fonction de la politique
salariale des entreprises c'est le cas
de la taxation des revenus financiers ou
de la suppression progressive des
exonérations de cotisations sociales
c'est également le cas de certaines
mesures que vous aviez vous même déposé
ou soutenus quand vous étiez dans
l'opposition comme l'amélioration du
dispositif fiscal sur les retraites
chapeau ou les mesures de réduction des
exonérations aux employeurs qui ne
respectent pas l'égalité salariale en un
mot vous êtes volontairement privé de
recettes précieuse au moment même où les
besoins de santé augmenter les besoins
en général augmente vous avez ainsi pris
vos responsabilités
votre obstination à poursuivre dans la
même voie sans écouter votre refus
d'associer le sénat au redressement
notre système de protection sociale en
refusant le débat sur certaines
propositions nous contraindra donc si
notre monsieur on n'est pas adoptée ne
présenter que des amendements de
suppression sur certains articles et à
ne prendre part aucun vote excepté les
votes sur les articles et sur l'ensemble
du projet de loi au final nous voterons
comme en première lecture contre la
partie recettes de ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
merci la parole est à monsieur alain
bertrand pour le groupe rdse
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur
depuis examen par le sénat de votre
blocry demandé par le gouvernement il ya
deux semaines le texte a chargé mais
finalement assez peu changé certes
également adopté par le sénat avait fait
pourtant l'objet d'un assez large
consensus
je ne reviendrai pas sur le recours au
vote bloqué un bon président jacques
mézard a parfaitement exprimé la
position du groupe dans le texte qui
nous reviennent de l'assemblée nous
regrettons le maintien de la clause de
désignation prévu à l'article 12 ter
cette disposition qui revient par le
biais d'un amendement qui avait été
censuré par le conseil constitutionnel
ne nous semble pas bon non
d'un même façon vous avez choisi de
reconnu respecte à sion du produit de la
contribution additionnelle de solidarité
pour l'autonomie au fonds de solidarité
vieillesse cette contribution
institué en 2013 devait pour alimenter
la caisse nationale de solidarité pour
l'autonomie pour financer la future
réforme de la dépendance
l'année dernière vous nous aviez assuré
madame la ministre qu'elle serait
effectivement affecté après 2013 à la
prise en charge des personnes âgées
donc certes les députés ont restitué à
la
cns à 5 millions d'euros dont une partie
devrait servir à financer les actions
destinées à la restructuration des
services d'aidé et d'accompagnement à
domicile
on peut toutefois pas satisfaire puisque
ça aurait dû rapporter près de 640
millions d'euros on regrette aussi
l'absence de réformes structurelles
comme vous l'aviez annoncé
lors de vue le 23 septembre dernier lors
de la présentation de la feuille de
route et de votre stratégie nationale
madame la ministre de santé voilà donc
nous pensions qu'il fallait
des mesures plus importantes et pas que
des mesures d'ajustement en revanche et
nous sommes satisfaits de la nouvelle
rédaction de l'article 8 qui recentre le
dispositif sur les seuls gains issus des
contrats d'assurance vie
multisupports exonérée sur le revenu
nous saluons également madame la
ministre les mesures relatives à la
contraception des mineures
à nouvelle lecture l'assemblée nationale
a adopté un amendement visant à garantir
l'anonymat de ces jeunes filles c'est
une bonne chose
s'agissant du sevrage tabagique
notre collègue robert tropéano en
première lecture avait proposé un
remboursement intégral
vous avez été à l'écouté madame la
ministre s'était pour de cette
proposition et nous vous en remercions
votre réponse va dans le sens de nos
attentes
enfin nous nous félicitons de
l'amendement que vous avez fait adopter
madame la ministre à l'assemblée
nationale en nouvelle lecture il s'agit
de l'aide à la complémentaire santé pour
les personnes âgées de plus de 60 ans
que vous portez de 550 euros soit une
augmentation de 10% nous savons bien que
les tarifs des complémentaires ont
tendance à augmenter avec avec l'âge ce
coup de pouce devrait compenser ce
phénomène c'est une excellente chose
s'agissant justement des retraités
modestes le premier ministre s'est
récemment engagé à revaloriser en 2014
le minimum vieillesse à deux reprises
1er avril et 1er octobre c'est là aussi
une très très bonne mesure le report de
la valorisation des retraites
touchera par des effets de seuil de
plein fouet ce qui sonne juste au dessus
et là il faudra aussi madame litres
faire un effort la précarité des
retraites est une réalité sera en
rapport de l' ocde il publié il ya deux
jours il ya de forts risques de pauvreté
pour les futures générations
deux retraités mais nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir avec vous sur ce
point lors de la nouvelle lecture du
projet de loi garantissant l'avenir la
justice des systèmes de retraite des
évolutions donc madame la ministre m et
mes chers collègues dans ces conditions
le groupe du rassemblement démocratique
social européen dans sa grande majorité
ne s'opposera pas à l'adoption de cette
ultime version du projet
de loi des finances sécurité sociale
pour la partie recettes et s'opposera
par contre à l'unanimité à l'adoption de
la motion condamneront poser la question
préalable et il y aurait chers collègues
beaucoup pas d'hier puisque nous aussi
nous voulons c'est sauver le système de
santé nous voulons sauver le système de
sécurité sociale nous voulons sauver le
système de santé public à la française
et nous présente que c'est en
accompagnant ce que fait le gouvernement
de bons parce qu'il ya des bons à mesure
que nous pouvons y arriver même si nous
on ne critique sur les aspects et c'est
le jeu de la démocratie qui ne
conviennent pas complètement à ce que
nous aurions souhaité voilà merci merci
monsieur bertrand la parole est à madame
aline archimbaud pour le groupe écologie
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur général chers collègues
après le rejet de la partie recettes de
ce projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale en première lecture et
après une commission mixte paritaire
infructueuses nous voici à nouveau
réunis en seconde lecture pour discuter
des finances de notre système de
protection sociale
comme nous l'avions comme nous l'avions
signalé en première lecture ce plfss
contient beaucoup d'objectifs généraux
que nous soutenons et plusieurs mesures
concrètes qui représentent des avancées
qu'elle concerne l'offre de soins de
premier recours la promotion des
génériques le recours à
l'expérimentation pour tester de
nouvelles méthodes innovantes ou encore
l'ex l'élargissement de l'expérience
concernant les nouveaux modes de
rémunération
nous avons par ailleurs suivi avec la
plus grande attention les débats qui ont
eu lieu à l'assemblée nationale où nos
collègues ont eu la chance de pouvoir
examiner l'ensemble des parties de ce
texte est donc de discuter des dépenses
notre groupe se félicite notamment du
fait que l'assemblée nationale est
remanié l'article 15 bis sur les
boissons énergisantes afin de se
prémunir contre une nouvelle censure du
conseil constitutionnel qu'elle ait
renforcé le dispositif prévu à l'article
44 au sujet de la dispense d'avancé de
frais or ticket modérateur pour les
consultations examens biologiques
préalable à la prescription de la
contraception destinés aux mineurs d'au
moins 15 ans en garris en garantissant
notamment l'anonymat des mineurs qui ont
recours j'ai également une pensée pour
les bénéficiaires de l'aide à la
complémentaire santé qui sont souvent
condamnés malgré les aides annexes mises
en place par certains ccas ou certaines
cpam a payé un lourd reste à charge sur
leur complémentaire santé je parle des
personnes de plus de 60 ans un
amendement du gouvernement adopté à
l'assemblée permettra de revaloriser
leur aide de 50 euros c'est un geste qui
leur sera utile cependant cette mesure
ne peut être qu une toute première étape
à l'heure actuelle en effet 70% des
personnes qui pourraient toucher l'aide
à l'acquisition d'une complémentaire
santé n'en bénéficient pas carélie
recourent pas ou n'arrivent pas au bout
de leur démarche et tout cela évidemment
reste préoccupant aussi ne pouvons-nous
pas nous satisfaire de cette simple
augmentation il faudra t'il de manière
urgente réfléchir à une simplification
de l'accès à certaines autres groupe a
déposé plusieurs amendements en ce sens
qui propose notamment une automaticité
réel entre le bénéfice de la spa de la
hache et l'obtention de l'aide à
l'acquisition d'une complémentaire santé
sans aucune démarche qu'ont
supplémentaire pour le bénéficiaire ce
qui on le sait sera favorable et à la
santé publique et au désengorgement des
cpam et à la surcharge leur personnel
mais puisque le temps ne me permet pas
de développer davantage je conclurai
simplement en exprimant par ailleurs
notre lourde déception lourde déception
que des amendements adopté en première
lecture au sénat sur les retraites
chapeaux les clauses de désignation le
covoiturage ou encore les données
sociales les entreprises n'ont pu être
retenues du fait du déroulé de la
procédure lourde déception que le
gouvernement n'ait donné d'avis
favorables à aucun de nos cinquante
amendement en première lecture lourde
déception qui certains amendements
fondamentaux pour la santé publique de
nos concitoyens des bénéfices et parfois
que des douze voix écologistes et sur
des sujets aussi importants que le
diesel l'huile de palme l'aspartame ou
encore le mercure dentaire et alors même
que certains avaient été adoptées l'an
dernier au sénat chers collègues quand
ces scandales sanitaires éclateront on
pourra pas dire qu'on ne savait pas
lourde déception fin que ce plfss 2014
n'engage toujours pas des changements
plus importants la prévention qu'elle
soit sanitaire ou social c'est du bon
sens personne ne vous dira qu'il est
contre en paroles mais plfss après plfss
force est de constater que c'est
toujours pour l'année prochaine
quand va-t-on passer aux actes et passer
aux actes dans un débat budgétaire bien
sûr c'est faire des arbitrages
différents et ce n'est pas selon nous en
continuant à fermer les yeux sur les
dangers d'un certain nombre de produits
qu'ils s'agissent des perturbateurs
endocriniens des particules fines des
ogm du mercure dentaire des ondes
électromagnétiques de la radioactivité
de l'amiante ou encore de certains
médicaments que nous y parviendrons
lourde déception enfin qu'aussi peu des
propositions contenues dans le rapport
remis au premier ministre fin septembre
soit reprise et ceci malgré l'ouverture
d'esprit monsieur le rapporteur général
de vous avez fait preuve ce rapport fait
en effet des propositions à notre portée
immédiate pour des simplifications
administratives drastique et urgentes
qui concerne des millions de nos
concitoyens permettant d'améliorer
l'accès à des droits comme la
complémentaire cmu l'aide médicale
d'état et l'aide à l'acquisition de la
complémentaire santé d'autres concernent
le tiers payant la limitation des
dépassements d'honoraires et plus
généralement la limitation des
inégalités d'accès à la santé alors oui
madame la ministre vous me répondrez
qu'une grande loi de santé publique est
en cours de préparation
nous l'attendons mais nous ne comprenons
pas pourquoi en attendant ne pas mettre
en oeuvre dès à présent dès cette année
des mesures urgentes attendu par
beaucoup par beaucoup d'acteurs
professionnels de la santé du travail
social qui nous l'ont dit dans les
auditions dans les 240 audition nous
avions fait et qui sont à notre portée
alors nous écologistes nous aussi
voulons réduire les déficits sociaux
nous aussi pensant pensons que c'est une
nécessité absolue
mais justement comment s'y prendre quand
on sait combien le renoncement aux soins
liés aux inégalités d'accès aux soins
quand on sait combien la faiblesse de la
politique de prévention coûte à
l'assurance maladie des sommes
colossales alors nous disons pourquoi
n'en tirons nous pas des conclusions qui
s'imposent dans les arbitrages
financiers je vous remercie
merci madame la parole est à monsieur
alain milon pour le groupe ump
menés sur panneau
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
pour cette nouvelle lecture du projet de
loi de financement de sécurité sociale
je vais madame la ministre vous épargner
de longs discours même si certains de
mes propos risque d'être redondant avec
se prononcer en premier lecture mais
selon nous il n'est pas inutile parfois
de répéter pour être un jour peut-être
compris en fer en effet le test que nous
examinons ce matin est la copie conforme
de celui que nous avons rejeté il ya
quelques jours je regrette que même des
amendements adoptés par le sénat à
l'initiative de notre rapporteur général
n'est même pas été retenu je pense en
particulier à la baisse du taux de la
cotisation versée par les établissements
hospitaliers au titre du financement du
fonds pour l'emploi hospitalier seul
l'article 8 comme demandé par le sénat a
été modifié substantiellement en effet
sous la pression du sénat des
associations d'épargnants le
gouvernement propose que la suppression
des taux historiques s'applique aux
seuls contrats d'assurance vie
multisupports alors que le premier
ministre vient d'annoncer une remise à
plat de la fiscalité
il n'est pas cohérent selon nous de
taxer les ménages à hauteur de 400
millions d'euros sur ce seul produit
d'épargné à l'occasion de cette nouvelle
lecture je souhaite revenir sur
certaines mesures qui n'ont
malheureusement pas été modifié je pense
au financement des mesures de
revalorisation des retraites agricoles
que vous fait peser uniquement sur les
agriculteurs
contrairement à la promesse du président
de la république de le faire porter sur
la solidarité nationale c'est l'article
9 il en est de même de l'élargissement
de l'assiette des prélèvements sociaux
qui s'applique aux exploitants agricoles
et du des performants de l'assiette des
cotisations d'assurance vieillesse de
base des artisans et commerçants a fini
au rsi même si la hausse elise c'est sur
deux années ces mesures participe de la
même logique toujours plus de
prélèvements en outre en instaurant une
troisième tranche dans l'assiette de la
contribution sur le chiffre d'affaires
due par les grossistes répartiteurs vous
risquer de compromettre
l'approvisionnement des pharmacies
d'officine et mettre en péril un pan
entier
la distribution des produits santé en
les concentrant entre les mains des
grossistes répartiteurs
s'agissant de l'article 12 ter qui
introduit de façon détournée
l'équivalent des clauses désignait de
désignation vous vous entêtez et passer
outre les décisions du conseil
constitutionnel
en effet celui ci a appelé par deux
décisions des 13 juin et 18 octobre
dernier que les clauses de désignation
porte à la liberté d'entreprendre et à
la liberté contractuelle une atteinte
disproportionnée au regard des objectifs
poursuivis de mutualisation des risques
cette clause de recommandations se
transformera donc plus en désignation
que le choix d'un autre organisme
assureur sera fiscalement censure
sanctionnés
je rappelle que le forfait social
passera de 8 à 20 % pour les entreprises
de plus de 10 salariés nous sommes donc
toujours convaincu que cette mesure
porte atteinte à la liberté
contractuelle
par ailleurs pour la deuxième année
consécutive
vous prévoyez de reverser le produit de
la casa au fonds de solidarité
vieillesse nous considérons qu'il s'agit
d'un détournement pur et simple des
fonds dédiés à la scène et ça et comble
du comble le texte voté mardi dernier
par les députés consacre seulement 30
millions sur les 100 millions envisagés
au financement d'actions consacré à
l'aide et l'accompagnement à domicile
ce détournement de plus d'un milliard
d'euros depuis 2013 nous fait douter de
la volonté du gouvernement de mener à
bien une réforme à la hauteur des enjeux
démographiques et financiers liés au
vieillissement de la population
quant à l'article 22 relatif aux
modalités du couvrement de cotisation au
régime social des indépendants
il n'apportera guère de remède aux
problèmes rencontrés par les petites
entreprises et les professions
indépendantes
l'important est d'entreprendre
rapidement une réforme de fond des
récits dont le fonctionnement a été
qualifié je vous rappelle par la cour
des comptes de catastrophes
industrielles c'est pourquoi nous nous
félicitons que l'amex et retenu notre
proposition dé travailler dans les
prochains mois en désignant comme co
rapporteurs jean-noël cardoux que c'est
jean pierre godefroy j'en viens aux
mesures relatives aux dépenses nous
sommes évidemment favorables à
l'amélioration de l'accès à la cs mais
la méthode que vous utilisez pose là
encore des problèmes comme l'appel
d'offres comment l'appel d'offres est il
être menée qui va décider des contrats
qui seront choisis en créant des
contrats dédiés à la cs puisque les
bénéficiaires seront obligés d'avoir
recours à ce contrat vous complexifier
le système et vous risquez une fois de
plus de stigmatiser ces populations ce
qui ne règlera pas le problème du non
recours de beaucoup des bénéficiaires
potentiels à cette aide en outre
déterminer un plafond au delà duquel des
organismes complémentaires ne doivent
pas assurer la prise en charge c'est
prendre le risque de créer un prix de
référence pour tous les produits or les
équipements d'optique et dentaires sont
venus nous avons tous des produits de
santé qui répondent aux besoins
individuels de chaque assuré ils sont
par essence tous différentes fixer un
tel plafond compromettra l'accès à
l'innovation est la qualité des chemins
et des assurés par les enjeux
économiques et l'impact social d'une
mauvaise vision ou d'une mauvaise
dentition sont importants pourquoi
n'avez vous pas choisi de mettre en
oeuvre la labellisation qui avait été
prévu dans la loi de financement pour la
sécurité sociale pour 2012
s'agissant des mesures concernant
l'hôpital je veux revenir sur la
tarification hospitalière qui j'en suis
convaincue doit être repensé mais
s'attaquer à ce problème comme vous le
faites par la mise en oeuvre des tarifs
dégressifs
de remboursement en fonction du nombre
d'actes réalisés est une fausse bonne
idée je vais déjà dis et je redis
volontiers elle constitue une nouvelle
régulation par les volumes qui risque
dans les faits deux fortement pénaliser
les établissements choisis par les
patients pour la qualité de leur médecin
et la qualité de leurs plateaux
techniques au final ce sont les patients
qui seront les premières victimes
puisqu'ils verront leurs interventions
repoussé voire des programmes et pour
éviter que l'établissement de dépasse
son volume d'actes
j'en viens à la création d'un collège de
financeurs chargé d'évaluer les modèles
d'économie des coopérations soumises par
les professionnels de santé dans le
cadre de la loi hpst
ajoutés au système déjà complexe prévu
par la loi une étape supplémentaire
risquerait de décourager les
professionnels alors que leur premier
objectif est de soigner et qu'ils ne
parviennent à se mettre en adéquation
avec les obligations administratives
nécessaires que grâce à l'appui des
agences régionales de santé ce collège
de financeurs ne doit pas devenir un
nouveau verrou bloquant des initiatives
de terrain à ce titre nous regrettons
que vous n'ayez pas repris la
proposition que j'avais faite avec
catherine génisson visant à créer les
modèles médico-économique que les
professionnels auraient pu reprendre
dans l'élaboration de leur projet enfin
je veux revenir rapidement sur une
mesure concernant le médicament il
s'agit la promotion des médicaments
biologiques similaires à travers
l'autorisation de la substitution en
initiation de traitement par le
pharmacien ce dispositif soulève de
nombreux problèmes il est selon nous est
indispensable d'attendre les conclusions
du groupe de travail sur les
biosimilaires met en place dans le cadre
du conseil stratégique des industriels
de santé en conclusion j'ose dire que
votre projet de loi de la ministre n'est
pas à la hauteur des enjeux ce plfss
consiste presque uniquement à assommer
de nouveaux prélèvements les retraités
les agriculteurs les indépendants les
famille et j'en oublie sans doute en les
assommant ainsi non seulement vous
compromettez l avenir de notre pays mais
vous n'avez même pas la garantie de
générer des recettes supplémentaires
aucune des propositions majeures
monsieur rapporteur général fait par le
sénat n'a été retenue vous en avez parlé
vous avez parlé d'une coalition
disparate chacun monsieur le rapporteur
a sa façon défend ses options dans ce
rappel fss il se trouve que notre
conclusion est la même et pour moi il
n'y a pas de honte à cela je ne vois pas
vous avez dit aussi monsieur rapporteur
que le sénat est tenu au silence je ne
suis pas d'accord avec ce que vous a dit
avec ce que vous avez dit je pense en
fait que les françaises et les français
apprécient plus les élus qui
réfléchissent qui propose que les élus
qui suivent la réflexion a porté par le
sénat et certainement par la population
beaucoup plus apprécié que le suivisme
apportée par l'assemblée nationale
merci monsieur milan la parole est à
monsieur jacky le menn pour le groupe
socialiste
c'est le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
je vais essayer à vous assure mais c'est
le terme et un esprit non pas par les
prélèvements mais par un temps trop long
dans mon intervention
la navette parlementaire pour ce projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
fait à nouveau escale au sénat dans un
climat qui pour cette deuxième lecture
semble même que lors de la première
lecture
cette nouvelle lecture du plfss 2014
aurait dû être une confirmation et un
approfondissement du texte en examen
hélas il n'en sera pas ainsi car seuls
nos collègues de l'assemblée nationale
auront pu contribuer à son amélioration
puisque en effet comme vous le savez au
niveau de notre haute assemblée en
première lecture la discussion a été
écourtée stoppé par un vote de rejet de
sa partie recettes nous empêchant
d'échangés sur le volet dépenses la
quatrième partie ce qui est
particulièrement regrettable est que
nous regrettons sur toutes les travées
de cette assemblée
j'ai tout lieu de craindre qu'il en sera
de même aujourd'hui
alors comme je lé fais mardi en séance
de la commission des affaires sociales
et avant que cette triste page de
l'histoire du plfss 2014 au sénat ne
soit définitivement tournée je vais
rappeler à nouveau un certain nombre de
points qui sont autant de vérités ou
pour le moins d'évidence que nos
collègues de l'opposition mais aussi une
fraction de la majorité sénatoriale se
refuse à entendre les uns à la noire
courte ou sélective ou bien leur
profession par positionnement tactique
puisque nous sommes dans l'opposition
posons-nous
mauvais soit leur servant la plupart du
temps de viatique les autres victimes
d'un illusionniste utopique qui les
égards inexorablement dans une idéologie
désespérée et désespérante du toujours
plus souvent enveloppé dans une posture
du type plus à gauche que moi tu meurs
donc je vais reprendre tout simplement
quelques-uns de ses points
premièrement un budget ne s'appréhende
que dans la globalité des recettes et
des dépenses son appréciation ou son
rejet
qui est tout à fait légitime
lorsqu'il s'impose ne trouve de
cohérence qu'à l'issue de son analyse
complète et non au milieu du gué comme à
l'occurrence ce fut le cas au sénat
cette année comme l'année dernière
deuxièmement le contexte économique dans
lequel ce budget s'inscrit ne peut être
ignorée pas plus que ne peut être
occulté la politique économique et
sociale d'ensemble qui le soutient
donc démarquant les paramètres dans
lequel ce préfet cesse 2014 trouve sa
place tout d'abord réaffirmant avec
force que nous sommes dans un contexte
économique en voie de redressement mais
encore marquée par les conséquences de
la crise économique qui bien évidemment
n'est pas passé la stratégie de retour à
l'équilibré repose sur un effort
renouvelé de maîtrise des dépenses
sociales
portées par des réformes d'ampleur sur
l'angle l'ensemble des branches de la
sécurité sociale dans un souci de
modération de la pression fiscale et
sociale dans les entreprises et les
ménages il y à bien selon nous est selon
moi en l'occurrence des réformes et des
réformes de structure n'en déplaise à
ceux qui ne sont pas encore repérées
mais on continuera les aider à voir où
nous en sommes ainsi les réformes des
retraites et de la branche famille pose
les bases d'une trajectoire crédible de
retour à l'équilibré
les mesures affectant les comptes de la
branche famille vise à recentrer les
prestations sur les publics les plus
fragiles
dans un objectif de justice et je répète
dans un objectif de justice par exemple
afin de réduire la pauvreté des enfants
et des familles le complément familial
sera progressivement majorée de 50% pour
les familles nombreuses vivant sous le
seuil de pauvreté une première
majoration intervenants à compter du 1er
avril 2014 n'est ce pas une mesure de
gauche mes chers collègues du groupe crc
s'agissant de la réforme de retraites
qui nous a longuement occupé il ya
quelques semaines nous rappelons avec
détermination qu'elle vise s'il vous
plaît vous écoutez qu'elle vise à
assurer l'équilibré des régimes de
retraite de base à l'horizon 2020 et à
maintenir cet équilibre à l'horizon 2040
conformément aux recommandations de la
commission de l'avenir des retraites les
mesures assurant l'équilibré ici 2020 se
doivent pour sauvegarder un système de
retraite que de nombreux pays nous
envient de concerner les actifs les
employeurs et les retraités
ces mesures en temps de faire face aux
défis que constituent à long terme
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie qui
est par ailleurs vous en conviendrez mes
chers collègues une bonne nouvelle pour
nos concitoyens en proposant une
évolution progressive de la durée
d'assurance pour l'obtention d'une
retraite à taux plein nous devons donc
en tirer les conséquences sur les plans
budgétaire et en l'occurrence au niveau
du plfss
à ce qui concerne l'assurance maladie
qui doit rester le pilier du financement
la prise en charge et soit nos
concitoyens comme le rappelait il ya
quelques instants madame la ministre
madame la mise des affaires sociales la
santé ainsi que celui du budget
relayé par notre à porter notre collègue
yves daudigny que je remercie à nouveau
pour le remarquable travail qui l'a
conduit avec ses collaborateurs
administrateurs la commission des
affaires sociales en longuement
développé en première lecture et encore
aujourd'hui au cours de leur
intervention la nécessité de concentrer
sur cette branche le maximum d'efforts
en matière de redressement des comptes
en 2014 pour des raisons évidentes
non pas d'ailleurs qu'on continue à les
lier sur certains rangs elle est en
effet la plus déficitaire
c'est comme se sont fortement dégradées
avec un déficit de cette année qui
devrait avoisiner les 7 milliards 7
euros soit 57 % du déficit du régime
général contre 44% en 2012 la réponse à
cette situation dangereuse doit être
courageuse
c'est cette voie du courage politique
que le gouvernement a choisi de suivre
et nous l'approuvons
la difficulté de l'exercice
nous que l'on ne peut nier à un effort
important de maîtrise des dépenses de
santé sans que soient pour autant
sacrifier les crédits affectés en équité
en équité par le biais de l'ondam au
financement des besoins de nos
concitoyens en matière de santé et de
soins et de recours au champ
médico-social
comment peut-on dire sans mauvaise foi
comme j'allais encore entendu avant-hier
en commission des affaires sociales
autant d'incongruités sur le taux de
progression de cette honda hm qui évolue
bien au delà du taux d'augmentation du
pib
plus de 4 milliards d'euros de dépenses
de santé supplémentaires
seront rendues possibles avec un ondam
en progression de 2 4% dans ce pays fss
2014 nos 900 à cette évolution positive
de l'ondam évolution positive de l'ondam
la maîtrise des dépenses de santé comme
l'ont expliqué tour à tous madame la
ministre et notre à porter notamment en
première lecture sera poursuivie
cette maîtrise sa compagne du
déploiement de la stratégie nationale de
santé qui fait largement consensus parmi
les acteurs du monde de la santé
ce déploiement je le souligne doit
permettre d'améliorer l'organisation des
soins et de rats force renforcer son
efficience
je relève notamment dans ce budget le
développement la chirurgie ambulatoire
et des actes de télémédecine
le développement de nouveaux modes de
tarification adaptée à une approche
reposant sur le parcours de soins
mesures concernant en particulier cette
année la radiothérapie et l'insuffisance
rénale chronique la pose des premiers
jalons d'une évolution en profondeur de
la tarification à l'activité qui reprend
de nombreuses préconisations issues des
travaux conduits en 2013 pour notre
mexes sénatoriales
enfin les mesures spécifiques qui ne
peuvent ni chers collègues nous avons
échappé en ce qu'elle favorise une
meilleure organisation des soins de
proximité
une grande loi de santé publique
dans laquelle prendra et villemin en
place évidemment place madame jouanno
un important volet prévention
viendra l'an prochain devant notre
assemblée dans la poursuite du
développement de la stratégie nationale
de santé avec ses implications
budgétaires dans les pires effets c'est
ce qui suivront
mes chers collègues
nous maintenant avec ce bel effet c'est
le cap fixé depuis le début de cette
législature
celui de la sauvegarde financière et de
la reconstruction de notre protection
sociale
mais nous faisons aussi la démonstration
que les contraintes financières s'impose
à nous qui s'impose à nous entraîne de
notre part ni renoncement ni immobilisme
ce préfet cesse et juste
ce préfet cesse et responsable se paie
l'effet cesse et sincère
c'est pourquoi madame la ministre nous
vous apportons notre soutien déterminé
ce projet correspond à nos valeurs et à
nos principes le redressement dans la
justice ainsi que la préservation et
même le renforcement de notre modèle
social auquel tous nos concitoyens qui
souhaitent notamment un haut niveau de
protection sociale sont très attachés
notre groupe votera donc
avec conviction et sans état d'âme ce
projet de loi en deuxième lecture tel
qu'il a été adopté par l'assemblée
nationale
merci monsieur le mène la discussion
générale est close nous passons la
discussion de la motion tendant à
opposer la question préalable
la parole est à de monsieur domine à
madame laurence cohen pour la motion
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues avec l'ensemble de
mes collègues du groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen nous avons pris
une décision importante à contrecoeur
mais qui je le crois témoigne de la
gravité de la situation pour la première
fois depuis l'élection de françois
hollande à la présidence de la
république nous sommes contraints de
soutenir une motion tendant à opposer la
question préalable sur un texte aussi
important qu'un projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
contraint par le projet de loi comme par
le contexte comment ne pas nous souvenir
qu'après trois jours de débat le
gouvernement à part votre voix madame la
ministre fait le choix de recourir à
deux procédures lourdes de conséquences
que sont le vote bloqué la seconde
délibération une seconde délibération
général réécrivant l'ensemble du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale tels que vous l'aviez imaginé
cette décision mais chers collègues
n'est pas anodine pour notre assemblée
comme pour la démocratie c'est un très
mauvais signal que vous avez envoyé en
tordant quelque sorte le cadre
constitutionnel
de telle sorte que votre gouvernement ne
soit pas confronté à la même situation
que celle sur les retraites ou le groupe
socialiste a été contraint de voter
contre un projet de loi qui même réécrit
apparaît c'est votre certes la seconde
délibération est prévue par l'article 43
alinéa 4 de notre règlement il n'en
demeure pas moins que son utilisation
aussi large pourrait écrire l'ensemble
d'un projet de loi est choquant elle est
même violente en ce sens que couplé au
vote bloqué vous niez tout à fait le
travail la réalité du sénat pour
justifier le recours à ces deux procédés
vous avez affirmé madame la ministre
qu'en agissant de la sorte vous vouliez
remédier au site un vote du sénat qui ne
traduisait pas la réalité de ces thèmes
ici mais de quelle réalité s'agit-il si
ce n'est qu'au sénat vous ne disposez
pas d'une majorité pour faire aboutir
des projets de loi de finances ou de
financement qui s'inscrivent et nous le
déplorons dans la continuité du
gouvernement précédent la réalité de cet
hémicycle c'est celle là al'inverse ce
que vous avez voulu en fait c'est
permettre au groupe socialiste de voter
pour le projet de loi quitte à
méconnaître au passage le travail de
notre haute assemblée qui d'ailleurs a
supprimé les amendements adoptés par le
sénat à l'initiative de notre rapporteur
des amendements que nous n'avons pas
nécessairement soutenu mais dont
l'adoption témoignait d'une certaine
forme d'accords et de consensus du sénat
cette réalité là vous avez également
fait le choix de l'ignorer au point que
je constate qu'à l'occasion de cette
nouvelle lecture notre rapporteur n'a
déposé aucun amendement
n'est ce pas indirectement un constat
d'échec face aux travaux du sénat qui
sont pas dans les fêtes reconnu mon
inquiétude est grande face à cette façon
de mener le débat parlementaire en
réalité le sénat est pris en
considération dès lors qu'il est un
soutien indéfectible à la politique du
gouvernement
ce n'est vraiment pas notre conception
de la politique si je voulais être
provocatrice je dirais que ce processus
apparente un vote de confiance ne
laissant pas d'autre choix parlementaire
que d'être derrière vous ou contre vous
et si je dis parlementaire et non
sénateurs c'est à 10 puisque vous avez
eu recours au même procédé à l'occasion
de l'examen par les députés du projet de
loi portant réforme des retraites à ceci
près qu'à l'assemblée vous avez seul la
majorité absolue c'est donc contre votre
propre camp que vous l'avez utilisé et
pour cause une partie des députés
socialistes sont hostiles à l'article 4
de la loi sur les retraites qui prévoit
le gel des pensions des retraités
pendant six mois il aura fallu pour les
convaincre de voter le texte final que
vous vous engagiez au cours des débats
sur la seconde lecture du plfss a
revalorisé au 1er avril au 1er octobre
les retraites est plus basse cette
annonce nouvelle nous conduit d'ailleurs
à vous interroger sur la manière dont
vous entendez financer cette mesure en
effet bien qu'ayant annoncé cette mesure
durant le plfss elle n'a fait l'objet
d'aucuns amendement rectifiant les
dépenses pourtant cette valeur
revalorisation devrait entraîner une
moindre réduction des dépenses nous ne
sommes pas opposés mais le principe de
sincérité budgétaire nous conduit à vous
demander comment vous allez équilibrer
les comptes tout cela m'amène après être
intervenus sur la forme en venir sur le
fond les deux étant étroitement liés
puisque ce sont bien vos options
politiques qui vous prive de majorité et
vous conduisent à recourir à de tels
procédés dans le même temps que vous
annonciez la revalorisation des pensions
pour les bénéficiaires de l'ass pas vous
annonciez un coup de pouce de 50 euros
pour permettre aux retraités de
souscrire une assurance complémentaire
cette mesure disons le clairement dans
le contexte actuel est positive tant le
nombre de retraités non couverts par un
contrat d'assurance santé complémentaire
est important les plus modestes
d'ailleurs renonçant à ces constats
qu'il juge trop onéreux ou tout
simplement qu'ils ne peuvent plus
financer or l'augmentation de l'aide à
l'acquisition d'une assurance santé
complémentaire est financé par le fonds
cmu c qui n'est lui même abondé que par
les organismes mutualistes
c'est à dire que l'état ne le finance
plus et au final les seuls à contribuer
sont les mutualistes c'est à dire les
salariés en décortiquant le dispositif
on s'aperçoit que derrière une mesure de
prime abord juste s'organise en réalité
une solidarité entre ceux qui bien que
modeste peuvent s'offrir une mutuelle et
ceux qui ne le peuvent pas les revenus
des capitaux se dédier à la spéculation
les rentes financières et immobilières
sont encore une fois épargnés à peine
jean marc ayrault at il annoncé une
réforme fiscale et pierre moscovici un
gel des impôts que vous les fait en
quelque sorte mentir en effet
aujourd'hui plus qu'hier vous faites
jouer aux mutuelles et assurances santé
complémentaires
une mission de percepteur qui n'est pas
la leur car pour financer le
renforcement de la cs plutôt que
d'instaurer un financement dédié vous
mettez à contribution les mutuelles or
ces dernières n'auront pas d'autre choix
que d'augmenter leurs tarifs elles
devront également le faire pour
supporter la ponction de 150 millions
d'euros que vous leur imposez aux ti du
financement des nouveaux modes de
rémunération
qui plus est vous avez renoncé à revenir
sur le doublement de la taxe sur les
contrats d'assurance que la droite avait
imposé sur les contrats responsables
non seulement cet axe est maintenue
alors qu'en 2011 il y avait au sénat je
vous le rappelle une majorité pour la
supprimer mais vous avez fait le choix
au titre de l'équité d'augmenter la taxe
sur les contrats non responsables
autrement dit votre conception de la
justice sociale c'est que pour rendre
une taxe injuste plus acceptable vous
augmentez une autre taxe de plus pour
rester sur ce sujet important du rôle et
de la place des organismes
complémentaires je dois dire que nous
contestons comme nous l'avons fait dans
la nuit du 11 janvier 2013 les clauses
de désignation rebaptisé clause de
recommandations sous prétexte de réduire
le reste à charge supportée par nos
concitoyens vous inciter fiscalement les
employeurs à souscrire des contrats
d'assurance complémentaire pour leurs
salariés et opter pour ceux recommandés
par la branche nous ne serions pas
opposer un tel mécanisme si celui-ci ne
s'accompagnait pas d'importantes
exonérations de cotisations sociales de
l'ordre de 2,5 milliards d'euros ainsi
au final au prétexte de développer les
tâches complémentaires de notre sécurité
sociale vous appauvrissez volontairement
le seul bien commun tous les salariés la
sécurité sociale obligatoire et lorsque
les employeurs ne jouent pas le jeu ils
ne perdent pas pour autant le bénéfice
des exonérations de cotisations sociales
puisque les employeurs ne seront au
final soumis qu'au forfait social
les employeurs qui jouent le jeu comme
ceux qui ne le joue pas peuvent toujours
compter sur vous pour pouvoir contourner
les règles relatives au financement de
notre système de sécurité sociale cette
obstination est incompris
incompréhensible car preuve est faite
que tous les cadeaux accordés aux
grandes entreprises n'ont aucune
conséquence positive et qu'ils ne font
qu'encourager le medef à en demander
toujours davantage pourtant vous
pourriez enfin vous saisir de nos
amendements que dans le passé et un
passé pas si lointain nous votions
ensemble je le dis avec d'autant plus de
passion que les salariés eux auront
moins de chance puisque les
contributions patronales à ces mutuelles
seront désormais réintégrés dans leurs
revenus nets imposables
certains salariés pourraient donc demain
devenir imposables comme tant d'autres
le sont devenus y compris des retraités
en raison du maintien du gel du barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu en première
lecture mon collègue dominique watrin
moi même étions intervenus pour dénoncer
un ondam insuffisant en baisse
importante par rapport à celui arrêté
l'année dernière nous vous avions dit
combien cet ondam allait peser lourd sur
les établissements publics de santé ils
sont confrontés à des difficultés
financières majeures et je crois que
nous en sommes tous témoins quand nous
allons visiter les hôpitaux de l'île de
france et de l'ensemble de la france
vous ne nous avez pas écouté le projet
de loi qui nous est soumis en nouvelle
lecture à grave encore cette question
puisque les prévisions dont dame sont en
baisse de 150 millions d'euros dans la
présentation qu'il en a fait devant la
commission notre rapporteur a présenté
cette baisse comme étant je cite une
politique de gestion rigoureuse des
dépenses d'assurance-maladie de
politique rigoureuse à politique de
rigueur il n'y a qu'un pas que vous avez
malheureusement franchi franchi pour
l'année prochaine comme pour cette année
puisque la campagne tarifaire que vous
avez menées cette année a été plus rude
que celle menée les années précédentes y
compris si l'on pense au gel des migac
et sachets une nouvelle fois que nous le
déplorons très vivement
d'autant que faut-il le rappeler les
établissements privés commerciaux sont
éligibles au cic ce que n'a d'ailleurs
pas manqué de dénoncer la fédération
hospitalière de france je m'associe
totalement au courrier adressé récemment
à la fédération hospitalière de france
par ma collègue eliane assassi qui
défend l'idée que les établissements
publics de santé puissent bénéficier
comme les collectivités locales du fonds
de compensation pour les emprunts
toxiques
ce que d'ailleurs mon collègue dominique
watrin a rappelé dans son propos
liminaire malgré les déments les
demandes formulées par les directeurs
d'établissement il demeure je vous le
rappelle exclus de ce dispositif et
cette exclusion nous choque puisque
beaucoup d'hôpitaux ont été contraint de
souscrire de tels emprunts pour investir
dans la mesure où progressivement l'état
s'est retiré voilà mes chers collègues
pourquoi nous vous invitons à adopter
cette motion tendant à opposer la
question préalable
monsieur d'houdini malgré tout le
respect que j'ai pour les travaux que
vous pouvez mener en tant que rapporteur
n'inversez par les responsabilités
l'obstination cas le gouvernement au
travers de vous madame la ministre à ne
pas nous entendre et parfois même à ne
pas nous répondre beaucoup des questions
que nous nous avons nous avons posé en
première lecture sont restés sans
réponse donc cette attitude nous donne
l'impression au fond de ne pas être
respecté dans la diversité de nos votes
c'est pourquoi nous pensons 20 d'entamer
ce débat puisque au final il était clair
que vous ne souhaitiez pas en tenir
compte
merci madame la parole est à madame
michelle meunier contre la motion
sur le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur général chers collègues nous
pouvons bien sûr avoir des regrets sur
le rejet du plfss par le sénat le 14
novembre dernier notre assemblée n'a pas
su en effet reconnaître et encourager
les efforts du gouvernement pour
défendre notre modèle social et apporter
des réponses adaptées au contexte et aux
besoins des françaises et des français
après le passage à l'assemblée nationale
et les améliorations qui ont découle j'y
reviendrai c'est maintenant au sénat de
prendre ses responsabilités
les auteurs de cette question préalable
estiment quant à eux que les conditions
ne seraient pas réunies pour que le
sénat délibère à nouveau et souhaite
donc ça que j'arrête là nos travaux dans
notre assemblée à nouveau et encore une
fois ce serait là à mon sens un bien
mauvais signal 1-2 trop peut-être à
envoyer à nos concitoyennes et à nos
concitoyens les auteurs de cette
question préalable considère que ce
texte n'est pas assez ambitieux et qu'il
s'inscrit dans la continuité des
politiques menées par le précédent
gouvernement
le précédent gouvernement où les
précédents gouvernements parlons-en de
2002 à 2012 la droite a accumulé 160
milliards d'euros de déficit pour ce qui
concerne la sécurité sociale ce projet
de financement de sécurité sociale pour
2014 quant à lui poursuit et amplifie la
stratégie de redressement des comptes
sociaux le déficit du régime général
devrait repasser sous la barre des 10
milliards d'euros l'an prochain il était
de 17,4 milliards en 2011 ce n'est pas
rien parallèlement le gouvernement a
engagé des réformes d'ampleur pour
moderniser notre protection sociale et
encourager la croissance et l'emploi à
ce titre le plfss permet notamment de
traduire les mesures annoncées en juin
dernier pour pérenniser et assurer la
pérennité de la branche famille et
rendre la politique familiale plus juste
mais c'est plus particulièrement sur la
branche maladie la branche la plus en
difficulté avec un déficit qui devrait
avoisiner les 7 7 milliards cette année
que les efforts se sont concentrés
l'objectif ambitieux est d'atteindre une
croissance de dépenses de 2,4 pour cent
en 2014 il faut saluer plus largement
ses efforts sa compagne du déploiement
de la stratégie nationale de santé que
madame la ministre a annoncé en
septembre dernier la démarche adoptée
par le gouvernement et cohérente
organisé et progressive et elle
s'inscrit sur les chemins d'une
amélioration durable du système de
protection sociale des françaises et des
français mais ce n'est pas tout ce plfss
point s'arrêter aux mesures d'économie
porte en lui des avancées juste
solidaire et significative citons-en
quelques-unes le renforcement des soins
de premier secours plus accessible et
plus efficace le sevrage tabagique pour
les 20 25 ans désormais trois fois mieux
remboursés par la sécurité sociale est
complété par la mise en place d'un
programme d'accompagnement le tiers
payant pour les mineures souhaitant la
prescription d'un contrat pas de
contraceptifs par un médecin de
meilleures conditions d'accès à la cmu c
est à une assurance complémentaire pour
les personnes les plus fragiles ou
encore l'augmentation du complément
familial pour les familles nombreuses
vivent sous le seuil de la pauvreté
parallèlement à l'augmentation de
l'allocation de soutien familial de 25%
à l'horizon 2018 concernant la branche
famille comment ne pas dire un mot sur
la convention d'objectifs et de moyens
que la caf a signé récemment et qui
traduit la volonté du gouvernement de
développer les modes d'accueil de la
petite enfance près de 275 mille
nouvelles places d'accueil sont prévues
dans ce cadre vous répondre aux besoins
des familles et soutenir la parentalité
au-delà des mesures inscrites par le
gouvernement au plfss l'assemblée
nationale vient de préciser dedans
richir le texte sur quelques points non
négligeables j'en citerai trois
l'article 8 consacré à la fiscalité
applicable aux produits de placement a
été profondément remanié conformément
aux annonces du premier ministre et aux
amendements présentés ici au sénat
l'article 15 a été modifié pour flécher
une partie du produit de la casa affecté
à la cns à vers le financement de la
restructuration des services dead et
d'accompagnement au domicile et
l'article 59 qui prévoyait le gel du
montant de la ls en 2014 a également été
amendée pour maintenir la revalorisation
l'année prochaine en la reportant au 1er
octobre il s'agit d'un bon compromis
c'est maintenant au sénat de prendre ses
responsabilités en poursuivant l'étude
de ce texte et pour cela je vous invite
à refuser l'alliance de la carpe et du
lapin qui réunissait autour de cette
motion les groupes qui considère que ce
texte va trop loin d'un côté et qui au
contraire ne le jugent pas assez
ambitieux cette alliance des contraires
ni lisible ni compréhensible ni
cohérentes politiquement ni donc voilà
si les auteurs de la question préalable
regrette l'utilisation d'une seconde
délibération et du vote bloqué en
première lecture nous nous regrettons le
détricotage quasi systématique qui a pu
s'opérer amendement après amendement par
cette alliance de circonstance plutôt
fâcheuses et autant au plfss sa
cohérence d'ensemble qui la faute mes
chers collègues vouloir le respect du
sénat et de son rôle dans le parcours de
l'élaboration de la loi est bien
légitime mais cela doit nous amener à
poursuivre nos discussions et nos
travaux sur ce plfss et je vous invite
dès lors à refuser l'impuissance et le
silence de notre assemblée en rejetant
la question préalable je vous remercie
merci madame meunier quel est l'avis de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
général
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues personne ne
sera surpris que j'exprime à titre
personnel mon opposition à l'adoption de
cette motion
sur le fond le texte qui nous est ce
matin transmis par l'assemblée nationale
est un texte équilibré
au niveau des recettes le gouvernement a
su entendre le mécontentement est
modifié
sans revenir sur ses objectifs initiaux
les articles qui posent des difficultés
je pense en particulier à l'article 8
concernant la fiscalité des produits de
placement je pense à l'article 10
relatif au déplafonnement des
cotisations vieillesse des artisans et
des commerçants
au niveau des dépenses bien que nous
n'ayons pas eu l'occasion d'en discuter
en séance mais suit notamment notamment
au vote défavorable du groupe crc sur la
troisième partie ce projet met en oeuvre
les principaux axes de la politique du
gouvernement en matière de santé en
déclinant et cela a déjà été souligné
plusieurs fois ce matin la stratégie
nationale de santé mais aussi en matière
de vieillesse suite à l'adoption du
projet de loi garantissant l'avenir des
retraites ou encore en matière de
politique familiale
sur la forme permettez moi d'exprimer
mon étonnement sur le fait que votre
groupe crc reproche au gouvernement
l'utilisation d'une seconde délibération
en fin de troisième partie en effet je
rappelle que compte tenu des votes de
chacun des groupes cette partie aurait
quoi qu'il en soit été rejetée
conduisant de facto au rejet de
l'ensemble du texte et par conséquent à
la transmission à l'assemblée nationale
d'une page blanche conduisant donc
l'assemblée nationale a examiné ce père
fss dans la rédaction qu'elle avait
adopté en première lecture
cette seconde délibération
a donc et en tout le monde assume
simplement permis de clarifier la
position des différents groupes au
regard de la politique menée par le
gouvernement
il s'agit donc d'un usage tout à fait
spécifique de la procédure parlementaire
qui ne paraît pas contradictoire avec
les droits du parlement je note enfin
pour le regretter
au nom de la défense des droits du
parlement ils soient déposés sur ce
texte une question préalable qui nous
empêcheraient d'en examiner le contenu
en séance en dépit de ces éléments donc
je suis ligne bien ici à cet instant que
la majorité de la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat a donné un
avis favorable
la nuit favorable à cette question
préalable
merci monsieur le rapporteur général à
vis du gouvernement madame la ministre
oui quelques quelques mots simplement
monsieur le président je ne vais pas
revenir sur le débat que nous avons eues
en première lecture qui a eu lieu
jusqu'au bout à l'assemblée nationale
mais je ne peux pas vous laisser dire
madame la sénatrice que le gouvernement
que je n'ai pas moi répondu à vos
interrogations et à vos interpellations
le débat a eu lieu la vérité c'est que
nous ne partageons pas la manière de
porter les politiques sociales et
l'avenir de notre protection sociale
dans les années qui viennent la vérité
c'est que le gouvernement se refuse à
faire une politique qui se contentent de
nouveaux prélèvements alors que des
prélèvements sont nécessaires et ont eu
lieu sans engager des réformes et des
transformations de fonds et ce sont à
ces 37 à ces transformations de fond en
matière de retraite politique familiale
d'assurance maladie que le gouvernement
s'est attelé donc moi je ne serai pas
plus longs que ceux là j'admets que nous
ayons un débat sur le fond et ce débat
gelé mené avec vous je le mène
d'ailleurs en dehors de cet hémicycle en
dehors de l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale nous l'avons dans le pays mais
je ne peux pas vous laisser dire que sur
la forme il y aurait eu une forme de
comment dire de refus de répondre ou
d'engager le débat en revanche oui
j'assume que le gouvernement
propose une politique qui est une
politique qui vise à la fois à définir
les exigences financières l'exigence de
répondre de façon responsable aux
besoins financiers et à la volonté que
cela se fasse dans un cadre de
solidarité et de justice parce que nous
ne pourrons pas porter des anges des
objectifs et des volontés sociale si
nous ne faisons pas en sorte dans le
même temps de rétablir l'équilibré de
nos comptes sociaux la question n'est
pas de savoir si nous pouvons nous
devons ou pas à rétablir l'équilibré des
comptes sociaux dans un contexte qui
rend ce rétablissement plus difficile
puisque évidemment lorsque la croissance
est là lorsque
les ressources sont là grâce à la
croissance il est plus simple d'affecter
des ressources aux politiques sociales
la question n'est pas de savoir si nous
devons le faire mais si nous pouvons
accepter que ce soient les générations
futures qui non seulement paix mais
assume la nécessité de répondre de
manière plus appropriée aux besoins
sociaux qui s'exprime dans le pays parce
que aujourd'hui il y a une exigence özil
à une exigence financière mais il ya
aussi l'exigence d'adapter nos
politiques sociales et faire comme si le
seul débat devait être celui de
l'immobilisme et du déversement de
ressources toujours plus forte pour
apporter des réponses à des besoins qui
évoluent en matière de retraite nous
savons que les carrières
professionnelles se diversifie et qu'il
faut répondre à cette diversification en
matière d'assurance maladie nous savons
que le grand défi est celui de la
proximité d parcours de soins et d'une
hospitalisation
maîtrisé en matière de politique
familiale nous savons que nous devons
répondre aux besoins de conciliation
entre vie professionnelle et vie
familiale si nous ne voulons pas voir
que tout en assumant la nécessité d'un
pacte social fort ce pacte social pour
être acceptée pour êtres vivants pour
être
durable doit aussi s'atteler à la
réponse des défis d'aujourd'hui et pas
simplement reproduire les réponses aux
défis d'hier alors nous ne pourrons pas
convaincre les français que nous sommes
aujourd'hui en phase avec leurs
préoccupations donc je le dis clairement
je ne suis pas en accord avec la
démarche qui est la vôtre le débat ne
peut pas aller beaucoup plus loin dans
le cadre de cet hémicycle in d'ailleurs
pas aller très loin la dernière fois
même si nous y avons passé des heures et
des jours puisque il y a eu un rejet de
la première partie qui nous est la
partie financière qui nous a recettes
qui nous a empêchés d'aborder le débat
au fond sur les politiques que nous
portons qu'il s'agisse de l'assurance
vieillesse même si nous l'avons vu dans
le cadre de la présentation la loi
retraites mais la politique familiale et
la politique d'assurance maladie donc
c'est vrai que j'entends la démarche qui
est la vôtre je donne par principe un
avis défavorable à la motion que vous
présentez mais vous entendez bien que
c'est un avis de principe parce que au
fond le débat il est bien celui là il
est celui de la nature des politiques
sociales et la conception du de la
protection sociale que nous voulons
porter revendiquer la protection sociale
oui mais revendiquaient une protection
une protection sociale moderniser est en
tout cas cela l'objectif du gouvernement
merci madame la ministre nous allons
passer aux explications de vote je
rappelle qu'il ya un seul orateur par
groupe qui dispose de cinq minutes
maximum la parole est à monsieur kardous
pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président madame le ministre
chers collègues il se passe des choses
étonnantes à la haute assemblée depuis
quelques temps avec cette méthode du
gouvernement de réintroduire par voie
d'amendement et provoquer un vote bloqué
le texte de l'assemblée nationale c'est
ce que nous avons qualifié récemment de
démocratie d'entêtement hier soir à
l'occasion du débat sur le plf certains
intervenants ont pointé du doigt
l'opposition lui reprochant par son
attitude d'empêcher d'église l'examen du
volet dépenses de ces deux textes
fondamentaux mais à qui la faute à la
carpe ou au lapin
euros c'est à dire aux parlementaires
qui expriment leurs convictions à
travers des choix politiques ou aux
gouvernements en mal de sa majorité
issus d'une campagne électorale dont le
seul dénominateur commun a été son
opposition au président sortant
nous en payons aujourd'hui les
conséquences avec cette attitude de
mépris à l'égard du travail
parlementaire
voilà pourquoi l'ump votre cette
question préalable en ne retenant que
les deux premiers paragraphes de
l'argumentaire du groupe crc son
initiateur avec lequel personne ne sera
surpris
certaines divergences sur le fond sont
assez fréquentes entre nos deux groupes
quant au nouveau texte proposé il
traduit une fois de plus une modeste
tentative de replâtrage de la part du
gouvernement on ne sait plus s'il s'agit
de tango de valse hésitation en
apportant quelques petites modifications
pour essayer d'attirer un certain nombre
de votes favorables alors genèse
énumérait pas tous alain milon l'a fait
parfaitement auparavant l'article 8
l'article 8 c'est celui qui était le
plus modifié en retirant de la taxation
les pea et les pel mais en maintenant
les contrats d'assurance vie
fondée sur des supports des supports en
actions dont contre l'économie alors que
le gouvernement propose je compterai on
en quelques temps l'article 10
article 10 où on dit on a modifié ce
lissage de la cotisation
déplafonné des professions indépendantes
mais lissage ça veut dire qu'on va
l'appliquer sur deux ans on ne sait pas
dans quelles conditions puisque on va le
déterminer ultérieurement
l'article 15 où on a dirigé 30 millions
d'euros de la casa vers l'action en
faveur des services à la personne des
services à domicile mais tout ça c'est
c'est des petites mesures c'est un petit
peu de replâtrage comme je le disais
mais il reste aussi il reste aussi ce ce
sinistre article douce terre sur la
clause de désignation travesti en
recommandations que le gouvernement veut
réintroduire contre l'avis du conseil
constitutionnel et que est rejetée par
tous des professionnels de l'assurance
et je dois dire madame dominique je
suppose que vous avez parfaitement
écoute et votre majorité à l'assemblée
nationale que l'éminent président des
lois monsieur urvoas éminent juriste
également a émis des plus vives réserves
quant à la constitutionnalité de ce
article douce terre nous verrons bien ce
qu'il en ressortira une fille née alors
c'est replâtrage c'est qu'elle sait tout
et c'est bien peu finalement voilà
pourquoi le groupe le groupe ump va
maintenir son opposition à ce texte et
en conclusion je dirais pour éviter que
de telles situations
donnant un piètre image du débat
politique de l'action politique et de la
haute assemblée pour que de telles
situations ne se reproduisent pas eh
bien il faudrait tout simplement que le
gouvernement
accepte d'agir tout simplement en fixant
un cap un cap qui soit lisible et
compréhensible équipe serait susceptible
de fédérer de majorité
mr c'est la parole est à madame aline
archimbaud pour le groupe écologie
monsieur le président madame la ministre
et chers collègues le groupe écologiste
votera contre cette motion est pour deux
raisons tout d'abord parce que nous ne
pouvons pas accepter de cautionner le
point de vue selon lequel ce plfss se
situerait dans le simple prolongement
de la politique du gouvernement
précédent je pense que nous devons pas
être amnésique et nous devons nous
souvenir que le gouvernement précédent
les plfss sous le gouvernement précédent
on a cumulé renforcer développer les
déficits des comptes sociaux qui l'ont
permis de renforcer et de faire exploser
les inégalités sociales en général et
les inégalités dans l'accès aux soins et
à la santé
je n'oublie pas un certain nombre de
discours que j'ai entendu également de
stigmatisation des chômeurs des
précaires et des explications qui nous
était donnée à l'époque par les
responsables gouvernementaux
nous disons que pour réduire le déficit
de l'assurance maladie il fallait
c'était la solution miracle
chassez la fraude sociale des plus
pauvres donc c'était évidemment une
illusion les les études encore récentes
ont montré que les solutions sont
ailleurs c'est la première raison pour
laquelle nous voterons contre cette
motion qui est défendue au nom entre
autres de cet argument la deuxième
raison qui fait que nous voterons contre
c'est d'autres collègues ont évoqué
également cette raison le souci que nous
avons de privilégier en toutes
circonstances le débat démocratique
ce débat nous paraît d'autant plus
important dans une société qui traverse
une crise économique sociale
démocratique et moral très profonde ou
une société dans laquelle se développent
l'angoissent les crispations chez nos
concitoyens les corporatismes de toutes
sortes les pertes de repères perte du
souci de l'intérêt général et
société dans laquelle aussi on a un
certain nombre de tentatives
de discours de manipulation de l'opinion
publique extrêmement démagogue populiste
et là souvent aussi tenus par des
extrémistes dangereux c'est donc pour
cette raison que nous regrettons la
situation qui fait que pour la deuxième
année consécutive une des deux chambres
parlementaires française n'aura pas
l'occasion d'examiner ce sujet aussi
important que les dépenses de la
sécurité sociale qui nous le rappelons
représente environ un quart de notre pib
c'est à nouveau toute la question d'un
début de réforme de la politique de
santé de la politique familiale de la
politique en direction des personnes
âgées qui ne seront pas débattue dans
cette assemblée il n'y aura pas
confrontation démocratique des points de
vue alors c'est pour nous en tant que
sénateur et je sais que certains
collègues partagent cet avis cela doit
nous interroger sur notre rôle sur le
sens de notre mission sur l'utilité de
l'énergie que nous dépensons à analyser
les projets de loi à préparer des
amendements voilà donc pour ces deux
raisons fondamentales nous nous nous
voterons contre cette motion
merci madame la parole est un monsieur
françois fortassin pour le groupe et
garder est ce un monsieur bertrand
pardon vous en prie oui c'est paris ben
moi je suis stupéfié alors que comme
mélange l'accessoire est le principal
parce que bon ce qui se passe ici c'est
un vote extrêmement important il s'agit
finalement de du marqueur essentiel et
entre une politique
progressiste tout simplement et une
politique
libérale ou de droite libérale ou
progressiste de gauche bien la saleté le
social la sécurité sociale les
stratégies de santé publique et les
français vont voir que le sénat a voté
contre la première partie du projet de
loi des finances insécurité sociale
arrive on se dira
et bien c'est certainement parce que
alors que
la gauche est censé être
majoritaire où les forces progressistes
que le projet de loi présenté par madame
la ministre marisol touraine à
l'initiative du gouvernement héros est à
l'initiative du président de la
république est mauvais or il est clair
que dans un contexte tendu dans un
contexte
de fort déficit public dont nous avons
hérité dans un contexte où je vous le
rappelle qu'à monsieur jospeh laisser le
gouvernement en 2002 les codes de la
sécurité sociale sont a vécu à l'
équilibre et en 2012 il sera prêt de 30
milliards de déficit est bien dans ce
contexte là le projet de loi présenté
par la ministre et marisol touraine où
le projet de finances du moins marquent
nettement une volonté politique
différente de celle du gouvernement
précédent qu'est ce qui caractérisait
les politiques de santé publique du
gouvernement précédemment et des
coalitions majoritaires précédente c'est
la volonté de passer le maximum de
choses au privé c'est moins d'un service
public c'est moins d'aménagement des
territoires par les politiques de santé
publique
s'est radicalement différent or parce
que un groupe de la majorité si j'ai
bien compris
en l'occurrence le groupe serré que
respecte parfaitement sa c4 pour ça
parce qu'il trouve qu'on ne va pas assez
loin que ça pourrait être mieux que
telles mesures pourraient être prises et
bien ce groupe se permet de renvoyer un
vote aux français qui va tromper les
français sur la nature de la politique
proposée par madame la ministre parce
que je le redis jean marc ayrault
fressoz lan man aventure elles sont
comme vous comme nous du camp
progressiste comme d'ailleurs une partie
du cadre républicain
tendue vers une politique de santé
publique qui respecte les conditions de
solidarité les conditionnels ménagement
du territoire et les conditions du si
mal finalement de la république
française donc c'est un mauvais coup
porté nos peaux sénat n'ont pas cela
mais c'est un mauvais coup porté à la
santé publique en france est à la tête
de nos concitoyens savaient déjà qu'ils
sont réseau très attaché à tout ce qui
se fait en matière de soins de famille
d'hôpitaux et compris dans la ruralité
et ils attendent de bons la décision je
crois que le pr le plfss présenté va au
maximum et vous avez vu les vous avez vu
les les progrès qui ont été faits grâce
à madame la ministre à l'assemblée
nationale et donc dire aux français ce
n'est pas mon texte s'est trompé les
français à ce qui concerne mon groupe
nous sommes tous contre cette motion
parce que c'est radicalement contraire
aux principes
progressiste et aux principes de respect
des citoyens français ce qui est le plus
important le service public la santé
publique
merci monsieur bertrand la parole est à
madame dîner pour le groupe udc
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre chers collègues à l'instar de
nos collègues des groupe crc et ump nous
pensons qu'il n'y a pas lieu de
poursuivre la discussion du plfss pour
2014 ceci pour des raisons de forme et
pour des raisons de fond sur la forme
comme l'a très bien expliqué ma collègue
chantal jouanno la manière dont le
gouvernement a traité le sénat
difficilement acceptable usé d'une
seconde délibération associé au vote
bloqué pour nous faire voter en première
lecture sur la troisième partie est
vraiment irrespectueux des travaux de
notre assemblée voici réunis pour une
nouvelle lecture et les conditions des
nouvelles conditions de travail ont été
les mêmes c'est à dire extrêmement
rapide puisque à peine l'assemblée
nationale avait-elle revoter le texte
que votre commission en été saisis et
ceci dans un délai horaire extrêmement
court
ça n'est évidemment pas des conditions
de sérieuses de travail mais tout cela
est également vrai sur le fond sur le
fond l'évidence c'est que vous ne
disposerez jamais d'une majorité dans
cette assemblée pour voter ce projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
l'assemblée nationale ni à apporter que
des modifications mineures en nouvelle
lecture dans ces conditions les mêmes
causes produisant les mêmes effets il
n'y a vraiment aucune raison que le vote
du sénat évolue aujourd'hui pour notre
part vous le savez nous rejetons ce
plfss
parce que son économie générale est très
inquiétante pour l'avenir il ne garantit
pas le retour à l'équilibré des comptes
sociaux son volet recettes comprend des
mesures que nous ne pouvons vraiment pas
accepter dont les plus emblématiques
sont peut-être celle portant sur le
retour de la clause de désignation et la
confiscation du produit de la casa ce
volet témoigne aussi d'une fiscalisation
désordonnée et non assumée du
financement de la sécurité sociale
en un mot beaucoup de bricolage
comptable et aucune réforme structurelle
aucune réforme structurelle non plus en
matière de dépenses en matière de santé
par exemple rien n'est fait pour combler
les multiples trous qui jalonnent le
parcours de soins et nous nous
inquiétons vivement de l'avenir de la
politique familiale qui n'a cessé depuis
l'alternance de faire l'objet
d'atteintes réitéré mais je ne serai pas
plus longue en conclusion puisque sur la
forme l'avis du sénat ne semble pas
requis et que sur le fond jamais une
majorité ne se dégagera dans cet
hémicycle pour voter ce texte il n'y a
effectivement pas lieu de poursuivre la
discussion et nous voterons donc la
question préalable merci madame la
parole est à madame meunier pour le
groupe socialiste
se prétend un ami cher collègue quelques
mots dans le droit fil du groupe rds et
du groupe
europe ecologie les verts le parti
socialiste mais les sénateurs
socialistes ne voteront pas cette
question préalable cela a été dit dans
les moments difficiles il faut du
courage en politique et ce plfss
pour notre part va dans le bon sens dans
le sens d'un projet justice sociale à
contraire à l'immobilisme que nous ne
pouvons prendre ici donc sans reprendre
les valeurs qui sous ten qui sous
tendent ce plfss et l'engagement vers
plus de justice et de progrès social sur
les quatre branches de la sécurité
sociale
je voudrais dire ici que l'image de
certaines coalition quand j'ai dit carpe
et lapin je le maintiens il n'y a aucune
lisibilité
rendues par ces alliances qui se forme
au gré des articles et au gré des
propositions de loi jeudi carpes et
lapins pour ne pas dire le loup et
l'agneau parce que l'histoire se termine
beaucoup plus mal
merci madame monsieur watrin pour le
groupe crc
oui je crois que nous avons suffisamment
expliqué le sens de cette question
préalable cependant je ne peux pas
laisser passer certaines formules qui
j'en suis sûr dépassent la pensée de
ceux qui ici sur certains bancs de
gauche les ont exprimés bon c'est pas en
parlant de carpes et de lapins ou
d'autres des animaux qu'on va régler un
problème de fond effectivement qui est
posée au sein de la gauche qui est posée
à notre pays et je pense que ça mérite
mieux que des formules à l'emporte-pièce
qui ne font que fuir le débat et nous
nous voulons que ce débat nous l'ayons
c'est ça la question que nous avons
cessé de poser pendant quinze heures de
débats ou plus lors de la première
lecture c'est cette question des
financements oui effectivement nous
avons une divergence de fond sur le
financement de notre protection sociale
eh bien je crois qu'il faut que la
gauche affronte cette question et nous
sommes prêts à le faire sur la base de
valeurs de gauche la réalité quelle est
elle c'est que bruxelles
l'union européenne telle qu'elle est
actuellement en place et qu'elle se met
en oeuvre ces politiques ultralibérales
est en train d'imposer des mesures
d'austérité à tous les pays d'europe
nous avions nous et parler de la
campagne présidentielle
effectivement entendu le président le
futur président de la république dire
qu'il re négocierait le pacte de
stabilité européen il ne l'a pas fait
donc aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui
s'applique une politique d'austérité
c'est ça la réalité des choses et où est
ce qu'on va chercher les mesures on va
les chercher sur les couches moyennes et
sur les couches populaires et c'est ce
que nous dénonçons je crois qu'une
certaine constance tout au long des
nombreux débats que nous avons soit ici
dans le cas de ce plfss soit dans le
cadre aussi du projet de loi de finances
ou sur la réforme des retraites on a
bien vu que cette réforme des retraites
n'était ni juste ni équilibrée et la
réalité pour ce qui concerne les
politiques de santé c'est que allez
peut-être dur à entendre de votre part
mais elle est là cette réalité c'est
qu'il y aura 600 millions d'euros 2 mois
pour les hôpitaux qui sont déjà en
grande difficulté alors non seulement ce
que nous vous reprocheront sur la base
de valeurs de gauche non seulement vous
ne prenez pas l'argent là où il est je
rappelle quand même que l'austérité
c'est pas pour tout le monde aujourd'hui
les plus grandes fortunes augmenté de 25
% leurs revenus faudrait quand même pas
l'oublier si vite les dividendes
augmenter de 5% et je pourrais aussi
donner d'autres exemples de la manne
financière qui n'est pas du tout
égratigné par les mesures que le
gouvernement actuel prend et c'est ce
que nous regrettons et c'est ça le débat
de fond c'est la première chose le
deuxième point c'est que ces mesures
d'austérité à nous à nous emmène à quoi
elle nous emmène à ce que les gens moins
de pouvoir d'achat nous emmène à ce qu'
il ya une baisse de la consommation à
nous emmène à ce qu' il y ait moins
d'activité économique elle nous emmène à
ce que au final tout ça se traduit par
de moindres rentrées fiscales dans le
budget de la nation c'est ce que tout le
monde a constaté et ça nous amène aussi
est ce qui est moins de cotisations man
recettes sur la sécurité sociale eh bien
c'est un cercle vicieux que nous nous
proposons de
rompre parce que je crois que sinon
effectivement ce raid est irresponsable
et on irait dans le mur il ya des forces
politiques à l'extrême droite qui
n'attendent que ça il n'y a pas d'un
côté je m'excuse des gens qui seraient
responsables
je ne sais au nom de quoi et puis
d'autres qui serait forcément
irresponsable parce que nous pointons
justement ces questions alors voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire ici vous
assurer que si aujourd'hui nous déposons
ça a été soulignée par ma collègue
laurence cohen une question préalable
qui est un événement exceptionnel
effectivement et bien c'est fort c'est
contraint et que c'est aussi une façon
d'appeler est ce que nous ayons à gauche
un vrai débat de fond pour notre pays
pour les classes populaires qui
souffrent aujourd'hui dans ce pays et
pour un nouvel à nouveau l'avenir un
nouveau destin nous l'espérons meilleur
pour ce pour cette france que nous
aimons tant
merci j'avais donc consulté le sénat sur
la question préalable opposé par
monsieur dominique watrin et les membres
du groupe communiste républicain citoyen
et dont l'adoption aurait pour effet
d'entraîner le rejet du texte en
discussion
je rappelle donc que la commission a
émis un avis favorable que le
gouvernement a émis un avis défavorable
et qu il va être procédé donc au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement et je demande
donc à madame et monsieur le secrétaire
de rejoindre la tribune
non
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin clos nous allons procéder au
dépouillement
je donne lecture des résultats du
scrutin 89 sur la motion tendant à
opposer la question préalable au projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2014 nombre de votants 346
nombre de suffrages exprimés
346 pour l'adoption
188 contre 158 le sénat donc adopté la
question préalable et en conséquence le
sénat n'a pas adopté le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2010 14 20 ministres mes chers collègues
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 15 heures pour les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
la séance est suspendue
comme on pouvait s'y attendre le sénat a
donc à nouveau rejeté le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2014 lors de cette nouvelle lecture
le texte va maintenant repartir à
l'assemblée nationale l'assemblée
nationale qui va donc rétablir le texte
dans une version conforme à la vision du
gouvernement l'assemblée nationale qui a
le dernier mot vous pouvez bien sûr voir
et revoir toutes les séances sur notre
site publicsenat.fr à 19h ne manquez pas
24h sauna notre rendez vous d'actualité
parlementaire présenté par delphine
girard très bonne journée à tous sur les
chaînes parlementaires
à